así colapsaban tres pisos de gradas en
el espinal en el centro de colombia fue
durante un espectáculo taurino conocido
como corraleja donde el público entra al
ruedo para enfrentarse al toro se
declaró la alerta roja en el municipio
ocho palcos oficialmente ocho palcos
colapsaron estructuralmente ya que deben
dar cuenta que esta estructura en
guaguas
estábamos como digo en el ruedo cuando
vimos el efecto dominó cayó esta
estructura el caos se apoderó del lugar
y medios locales reportaron que el toro
se fugó temporalmente de la plaza por
las calles del espinal mientras la
tragedia dejó un importante número de
afectadas pero de verdad que ve terrible
fue una traída de
desastrosa porque es un miedo
que verdaderamente
un cargo dividido
no es la primera vez que sucede algo
parecido en colombia en el año 1980 en
el municipio de sincelejo en el norte
del país murieron más de 500 personas en
un suceso similar un evento al que hizo
referencia el presidente saliente iván
duque prometiendo una investigación
después de que el presidente electo
gustavo petro se pronunciara en un tuit
esto ya había sucedido antes en
sincelejo le solicito a las alcaldías no
autorizar más espectáculos con la muerte
de personas o animales
el nuevo presidente llega rodeado de un
importante número de activistas por los
derechos de los animales y aunque este
tipo de festividades son típicas de
colombia por ejemplo en bogotá la
capital no se celebrará ninguna corrida
en 2022 mientras los legisladores
avanzan en el congreso con un proyecto
de ley para prohibir las totalmente